for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out
movie University com thank you and enjoy
okay next up we've got acids and how to
name them one thing I want to make a
quick note of is that there are a few
different definitions for acids and we
won't really talk about them too much
right now just for the simplicities sake
you'll learn more about them later for
now we'll kind of keep in mind is that
we could take an acid to be something
that is H a write something that start
with that hydrogen and then a is some
anion so H represent it will be V
basically coming from h plus in the in
the formula and the a is the a minus
okay and that represents some an eye on
okay or we can think about it as being H
X where X would be the anions magnitude
of charge right so in the first example
for H a it's really a combination of h
plus and a minus right you do the
crisscross method you get a che but if
the anions charge isn't just minus 1 you
have h plus and a X minus whatever that
X is do the crisscross method that X
becomes a subscript 4 H so we have h x a
ok so we could take anything with that
formula to be an acid okay at least for
now so there are two types of assets
that will be talking about and they are
binary acids and oxxo acids okay so a
binary acid resulted from the
dissolution or the dissolving this so
this solution of a gaseous compound into
ions in water as what a binary acid is
so an example is HCl HCL can be named as
a hydrogen chloride and I have a little
a little asterisk here indicating that
that's if you were to name it using the
covalent
compound naming system which is in the
next video just kind of little sneak
peek there maybe come back to this after
you watch that next video HCL would
split up into the ions h plus and Cl
minus ok so the a- here is really just
that that's co- right so the way we
named a binary acid is we would have the
prefix hydro prefix is always going to
be hydro and then we'll have after right
after that we'll have the anion root in
the case of of HCl we've got chloride as
the anion right so we're going to have
clore we're going to drop the ID there
so Clore okay that's the root of the
anion and the suffix will go from being
I'd to ache okay so hydrochloride of ID
will have it and then at the end we'll
just add acid so if we put this all
together this whole fist this whole part
here before acid is all going to be one
word so the name will be hydro kloor Eck
acid right the two separate words are
hydrochloric and acid okay so that's how
you name binary acids prefix hydro and I
on route change I'd to it and then add
acid at the end okay now the other type
oxxo acids they result from the a- an
eye on being an ox 0 ni on in the h a
right so an example would be HCL oh
that's made up of H+ right and the
oxyanion or ox 0 ni on CL 0 minus which
is hypochlorite ok so i'm going to write
that here in parentheses hypochlorite
right which we just have to have
memorized as one of the polyatomic ions
ok so how do we
this well what would name this is we
would have the ox 0 ox 0 and I on name
including the prefix right the prefix
has to remain there and if if it's there
right in this case we have a prefix hypo
right and what we do is we're going to
change the ending 82 or if the ending is
aight we change that to us ok I often
call this the a tick itís rule and
pretty much everyone calls it that at
least that I know ok and then at the end
we'll just add acid so in this case the
oxyanion name is hypochlorite right but
we're going to change the aight into us
ok so it's going to be hypo chlor us
acid at the end right and that's it
right so that is HCl Oh what if it was
HC 002 or hclo 3 or hclo4 right just cuz
these are all in the same family we
might as well just name them all ok now
the prefix only has to remain if it was
there to begin with right now HCL 02
comes from chlorite by the CL 0 to minus
is chlorite so we don't have a prefix
there we just have Clore and the aight
will become us right so it's going to be
kloor us acid ok with the next one HCL
03 we have CL 0 3 minus that's chlorate
so no prefix it'll be Clore instead of
eight that becomes kick right a tick I
us right so chlorate becomes chloric so
I'll be chloric acid and last one hclo4
clo 4 is perchlorate right so the prefix
/ remains and then we have the claw and
then we drop the eight replace it with
ich /
boric acid and that'll be the name of
that okay next up name the following
acid hcn well we have h plus and we have
CN minus so this is a binary acid right
because it doesn't have the anion is not
an oxyanion so we've got CN minus that's
cyanide cyanide right so this will be
hydro right the prefix hydro cyan and
then the eye becomes X I anak acid
hydrocyanic acid and that's it for that
okay so you might have noticed that up
until now all the acids that we've
looked at have been with only one H
these are called mono protic why is that
well mono means one protoc refers to
proton and if you think about h plus
that's really a proton right because
hydrogen just has one proton and one
electron in this electron cloud if it
loses that electron then it's really
just a proton right so h plus is a
proton ok so one h plus is monoprotic
okay there are some some acids that have
more than just one h+ right so in the
case here h2so4 we've got to H pluses
right this is considered diprotic okay
here again to H pluses diprotic and here
are three H pluses that is try protic
okay cool all right so what I wanted to
do is sort of mention that the something
that's i think is pretty pretty
important it's the idea there are six
strong acids that you should commit to
memory and here they are HCL HP rhi hno3
hclo4 h2so4 HCL is hydrochloric acid HP
RS hydrobromic acid h is hydroiodic add
acid hno3 is nitric acid HCl for is
perchloric acid h2so4 sulphuric acid you
should memorize all of those the
formulas write their formulas their
names and the fact that they are one of
these six strong acids okay now you
might be thinking what makes them strong
well they're strong because they
dissolve or dissociate into their ions
completely in solution so they go for
example HCL HCl is HCl like this if you
put it in water it's going to completely
dissociate into h plus ions and cl- ions
why exactly does that make it strong
well that involves defining acids which
I'm not really going to do in this video
I just wanted to talk briefly about how
to name them that way if you come across
acids elsewhere you will be able to name
them okay we'll talk more about acids
later and their definitions okay I hope
that video is helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying